so there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia : unusual
articles I just remember it as that
Wikipedia list it's a collection of
hundreds of articles about unusual
unexpected and unbelievable subjects no
matter what link you click it's bound to
be interesting for that reason every
week I'm gonna click on a new link and
teach you a little bit more about our
amazing world this number is illegal
well kinda I switch it a few digits to
protect myself since you know it's
illegal but just the possession of this
number is enough to get you arrested in
the u.s. to understand why we need to
learn some cryptology prime numbers are
numbers that can only be divided by
themselves and one for example nothing
multiplies together to get seven other
than seven and one
nothing multiplies together to get 29
other than 29 and one this will be the
same for all primes it's not that hard
to check if a smaller number is prime
for seven you just check if seven
divided by one is a whole number 7
divided by 2 by 3 by 4 by 5 by 6 nothing
other than 7 can divide 7 into a whole
number as you get to bigger and bigger
numbers you have to check more and more
times to determine if a number is prime
that means that it's exceedingly
difficult to find new Prime's the
largest prime number that we know of
right now is 2 to the power of 74
million two hundred seven thousand two
hundred and eighty one minus one there's
an infinite number of primes since
there's an infinite number of numbers
but it just takes an enormous amount of
computing power to find these Prime's so
what's the point of finding primes well
they're actually quite useful for
encryption for the sake of simplicity
let's take two small primes 11 and 13 if
we were actually encrypting data we
would be using Prime's with thousands of
digits but that would probably make this
explanation a little complicated now
multiply 11 and 13 together in your head
you can probably figure out pretty
easily that together they make 143 now
how long would it take you to work
backwards and figure out what multiplies
together to get 143 probably a pretty
long time it's the same with computers
it's very easy for them to multiply two
numbers together and find out what the
product is but it's very hard for them
to take the product and find out what
the factors are when you're logging on
to say your bank account online the
computer will send the number 143 which
is known as the public key to the bank
server the bank will then check if 11
and 13 the private keys multiply to 143
and if so it will let you in everyone
has the public key but only the bank has
the private keys if you wanted to find
the private keys you would need a
computer to factor the public key which
would take thousands of years because
once again in the real world
the keys are an 11 and 13 they're prime
numbers with thousands upon thousands of
digits with the amount of money that it
would take to set up a computer system
that could actually factor the primes
it's just not worth it the bigger the
prime number the longer it takes to
factor and the more secure it is
that's why organizations like the
Electronic Frontier Foundation are
willing to pay up to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for new prime
numbers alright
that's all the math we're gonna do today
I promise back to our legal number in
1998 the Digital Millennium Copyright
Act was passed in the US making it
illegal to circumvent copyright measures
and to produce or distribute tools that
could be used to get around copyright
systems our legal number eight five six
five zero seven eight and so on and so
forth is a prime number that is the
source code used to decrypt the
copyright protection of DVDs the
copyright protection was used to stop
people from downloading or duplicating
movies on their computers and with this
number the protection was rendered
useless programs were created that
allowed individuals to make bootleg
copies of movies all because of this
number all the while individuals are
breaking the law not only by copying
DVDs but also just by being in
possession of this number an easily
findable prime
I hope you enjoyed this week's episode
last week I covered Big Mac economics
which you can find here if you enjoy
these videos make sure to click
Subscribe here also please follow me on
my Twitter app went over Pro thanks for
watching and I'll be back next week with
a special video not from that Wikipedia
list